Alright. And welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Thursday,
which typically means it's cluster day, and
typically it is cluster day. We're doing cluster
today. We have two wonderful guests joining us
to
fix some rather broken Kubernetes clusters.
I'm going to be joined by two guests
in just a moment, but we do have
to start with a little bit of housekeeping.
And I was a little bit flustered because
one of my guests disappeared, but fortunately he's
just dialed back in. So phew, panic over.
So before we get started, there are two
sponsors of Clustard and I wanna thank them
both.
Teleport have been sponsoring us for a while
now. You're definitely no stranger to Teleport. We
use it every single week on Clustard.
Teleport allows us to use GitHub to SSH
to all of the machines, which are bare
metal machines,
and allows us to pair and collaborate
via SSH systems, typing them to the same
terminal to work out what is wrong. Teleport
is an amazing product that does much more
than just SSH access. So you should go
check it out at rockode.lifeteleport
and support the show. That would be amazing.
Thank you all very much.
All right, next up we have Equinix Metal
who are also sponsored by Clustered as well.
And they've always prevented the hardware for this,
so it was a no brainer that they
wanted to be more involved. And we use
some pretty chunky machines for Clustered because it
makes it more fun. We've got tons of
cores, tons of RAM, bare metal is a
fantastic way to check out Kubernetes.
So check out Rawkode. Livemetal.
Also, if you're already in the Equinix portal
and already know everything that you need to
know, then just drop it in the voucher
code Rawkode,
and this will get you 200 USD
and credits. This will allow you to spin
up one of their configurations of machines, depending
on what size you pick for up to
a hundred hours.
So go have some fun and play with
that too.
Alright.
There's one more thing. We have a competition,
which I'll get to in a second because
I've lost this thing.
Let's introduce a guest first.
Hello, Marcus and Lee. How are both doing?
What's
up, friends?
Hello.
Hello. I can I'm I'm doing a lot
better right now than I think I'm going
to be in just a moment here. So
Oh, you're gonna do great. I know why.
It's gonna be amazing. Let's start with a
little bit of an introduction. Can you both
we'll start with Lee and then we'll go
over to Marcus. Just say hello. Let us
know who you are, and then we'll take
things from there. Yeah.
Friends, I'm I'm so excited to be joining
Rawkode stream today. I have wanted to do
a a clustered stream since probably the first
episode.
I've been a a huge fan of this
series.
My name is Lee Kapili. I live here
in Denver,
and I have a history of writing software
to do operations stuff on platform engineering teams,
places like DIRECTV,
Beatport, and AT and T.
I did a stint as a developer advocate,
a developer experience engineer with the Weaveworks team,
also contributing to the Flux project and Kubernetes
projects. And now I work with team Tanzu
on a bunch of cool stuff with a
bunch of very humbling other developer advocates
and a staff dev advocate now. So pretty
stoked about that and stoked to still be
contributing to this awesome community and breaking stuff
just as much as I can fix it.
Awesome. Thank you, Lee. Marcus?
Cool.
Hey, everyone. I'm Marcus. I'm a platform engineer
with Giant Swarm.
I'm based here in The UK.
I don't really have as much to say
as leaders.
So let's just crack on.
Alright. Brave guests. Thank you very much. Now
I do have the stuff for the competition.
So if
you wanna win a new t shirt, which
we have here sorry, Lee. I'm gonna cover
up your face.
You can go to Rawkode.live.
Hold on. Yeah.
Go to Rawkode.live/win.
And this is the new cluster t shirt.
So you know, enter now. We're gonna give
them away. And if you join well, even
if you've already entered, go back and check
the link again now because
there's a new tweet that you could retweet
that will get you 100
extra entries into the vote. We will be
doing the draw after both clusters are fixed
or if both clusters are fixed, we're gonna
find out. So Rawkode.live/1
will get yourselves a t shirt.
Awesome.
Now before we went live, you can go
right back from center now, Lee. It's all
good.
We're gonna jump straight over and get these
things started. Lee is gonna go first.
So I am going to open a session
on
Marcus control plane.
Give that just a second. Now I gave
you both access. I modified your roles using
the Teleport UI and give you access to
every single machine. So you should be able
to see the active session
and join. I see that you're logged into
this one now.
I am here.
These past two days have been the first
time I've used Teleport ever, and I've been
really excited getting to learn to use it.
It's such a great tool. I mean, I
know they sponsor the show, but I I
would use Teleport regardless. It's amazing.
So
Okay. I'm in here.
Alright.
Set up your KubeConfig.
Check for our control planning. You have forty
minutes. Best of luck, Lee.
Okay.
Just give me a second here. I'm gonna
do a little probably a little bit more
than just setting up my kube config.
I'm going to pull up my GitHub
on my machine and just get
this
repository URL.
Simple.
Just need a little bit more of a
ergonomic experience here.
Okay.
Git clone.
Paste.
Oh, did I
Yeah. It does take the terminal. I need
to, like, reset it.
Here we go.
Clone.
And then
Wait a minute. So every time we have
issues with the size, reset is gonna fix
it?
Yeah. That's one of the things that you
can do. And I actually learned that, I
think, from a commenter.
I may have been doing a little bit
of studying over the past couple of days
to get some inspiration and to make sure
that I wasn't gonna do the same things
as everyone else. So
Yeah. That is they're permanently naughty because
XDRIP JS has caused us many issues with
shading EarthView.
So
fun story here. I'm actually joined in from
my own terminal using the TSH command line
tool,
and I had to recompile it to override
a behavior that was
not working with the ACLs.
Ah, so you've managed did you manage to
fix the TSH join command?
I don't know if I fixed it to
a place where they would merge it, but,
yes, the answer is yes. Marcus, I think
you're in trouble. A
little bit.
Yeah. So so I am I got full
copy and paste ability right here. I'm I'm
at home. I'm right here in my WSL
terminal. Like, we are we're ready to buy.
So, what do I gotta do here?
Well, I I
guess I could try to exec my bash.
I see. Oh, sick. Look at this. Look
at this. Almost like I'm, like, ready to
go here now. Alright. And then, let's go
ahead and just, like,
do one of these dudes.
If I can type properly,
which I cannot
still.
Group config.
It's gonna be
let's get out of the string for a
second,
Etsy Kubernetes
admin comp.
And then I will pop that into a
string, and then let's just echo that and
append it to
my bash r c
d just in case we end end up,
like, losing a teleport session or something here,
we have to re log in that I
don't need to do this
koop s h. How about that?
And while we're at it, I'm gonna add
an alias as well.
Good call. Is it even worth adding an
alias? K. Marcus has left me access to
koop c t l. Thank you.
K. Kubectl,
and then we'll do kubectl
completions
dash,
but that needs to be
oh, but my
I see. I need to, like, size my
terminal a little bit better here because yours
is a bit smaller than mine.
Hopefully, I can get this a little closer.
Okay.
K. S k.
Source.
K.
Russell's saying 5% of your time is already
gone. But sometimes it's worth setting up your
tools. Right? You mean how much time you
can save if I have it on times
I'm gonna type k.
Yeah. And then
this is another thing I had to reference
from my own dash r c.
Start kubectl.
K.
Completions.
Oh, yeah. There we go. Completion.
Cool.
And then
might as well
put that in my bash r c as
well. I probably shoulda had that in there
already, but
bash r c.
Toda.
We Oh, you put it in there. Alright.
Okay. Yeah.
Cube.
Cool. Alright.
K. Alright.
Let's go see where we're at. So
did I not
I don't think you have exported config.
Does not have the resource
type node.
Okay. Cool.
Do we have any resource types at all?
And can I even get maybe, like, the
cluster info to further
cluster info dump doesn't have the resource type
services,
so we cannot see what the Kubernetes service
IP address is? At this point, I'm kinda
curious. I might go into the
Kubernetes
manifestor
and just check a look at the kube
API server flags.
Seems reasonable. Right? Because, like, maybe we, like,
disabled some APIs here or something.
That's kinda my first guess.
The other thing that I'm thinking is maybe
I don't have access to the discovery API,
so then I don't have access to, like,
Kube API resources.
So it could be like an RBAC thing.
Let's
see.
If you can use less as a pager,
it just means we can follow your your
scanning as well. Oh, I see. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Because my terminal has its own pager.
Yeah. I can do that.
Sweet. I
don't remember to do that.
Yeah. I don't see any I don't remember
what the flag is to, like, enable particular
API groups and stuff. I believe it would
have to be done on the API server
because that's where all of, like, admission and
looking up API groups happens, and I don't
see anything in here that, like, looks super
out of the ordinary.
So the next thing that I'm interested in
is, like, maybe I can ask
who
I am.
And I need to find a resource where
it's gonna, like, give me an error message
or something that tells me who I am,
unless I can figure out
a
Well, you can run off can I on
its own, and it'll give you a metric
normally? No? Well, I thought it did.
I don't I I don't know what the
command for that is, but I've seen it
done before. Maybe chat will chime in. And
but, I mean, I can
it's just unfortunate if there's no resources. But
then, actually, you know what's what's special about
this, though, is that resources don't need to
exist in the cluster for you to actually
bind against them in RBAC.
So I should still be able to, like,
say, like, can I get pods?
And this is telling me that this is
okay.
I'm not expecting to see an NGINX
server
error coming back
from anything Kube Huddle related. So
I believe that we are being misdirected to
someone from the funky.
Think it's very take a look at the
kube config.
That's inside of Etsy Kubernetes manifest admin
conf
is, I believe, what we are using.
It is indeed.
So let's cat the admin conf
or, I guess,
less the admin conf.
Did I oh. Yeah.
So that's a server IP that's listening on
port four four three, which is not the
Kubernetes default.
But there is something listening on 443, which
I'm imagining is, like, some NGINX container or
system d unit or something.
And, like, it's worth looking into what that
thing is just to indulge
Marcus' ego a little bit.
So
yeah. I mean, I guess, like, some ways
that I could look at that is if
I have net stat, then maybe I could,
like, net stat plant and then grep for
NGINX.
And I see that there's an NGINX process
listening on four four three. Indeed. I don't
know what necessarily is running that,
but I could also check to see if
maybe there's a kubectl
or something.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Moxygo says that the kubectl plugin for the
matrix thing is
off can I list? Now I'm not even
gonna try that before we fix the kubectl,
though. So
just wanna maybe see if I can get
an editor assuming that my Linux server is
working,
which it seems so far, like, apt is
pretty happy with that. So that's good. I
like this editor. It's like a like, kind
of nano but bigger. So
you know? Hence the name micro.
Micro. Yeah. And so I might just go
and micro the admin conf and
add a six here and see if maybe
we are now potentially talking to Kubernetes.
So there's nothing there, and I might then
go check to see
if
oh,
Crackle config
sets.
Was it endpoint?
Runtime dash endpoint.
Time
dash
endpoint,
and then I need to set it to
Unix socket,
which is, like,
var run container
d container d sock. Cool. Yep.
So maybe let's go look to see if
there's some pods here.
And
it looks like the scheduler and the controller
Meowager
are
up, but the API server doesn't oh, here
it is. Okay. But then
the API server was modified.
I'm just deducing that because
was
probably spun up that forty eight hours ago,
and then here we have
you know? But does have a state of
not ready for all of those
containers.
Yeah. I don't remember if those are supposed
to be ready, but that's good to know.
So
let's go ahead and
get the containers instead,
which is
okay. So there's no containers,
which
indicates to me
that if CRI is up,
maybe there's something in container b that's not
configured properly
or, you know, we're not able
Yeah. You've missed yourself, Lee.
Sorry.
Can you still hear me?
Yeah. We can hear you now. You were
muted for a second. My,
headphones died.
I
should have charged this last night, but I
guess I didn't. Hopefully, audio is okay. It's
alright. Yeah. Don't worry about it.
Cool.
So,
I'm thinking since we can't create container sandboxes
and KubernetesM depends on containers,
that's the reason why Kubernetes is not up
right now.
And, we'll have to go and look at
why ContainerD is complaining.
So I think container d in this setup
probably runs with the system d unit since
we're on a Ubuntu system.
It's gonna, I guess. Yeah. System d is
our init.
Russell,
you mentioned that Kubelet might not be looking
at the manifest directory.
But even if Kubelet is not looking at
the manifest directory, there are pods here that
are inside of CRI.
So the Kubelet is
reporting that that we want, like, an API
server.
I haven't checked, like, the the spec here,
but I'm thinking we can
if maybe we're thinking that the manifestor isn't
up to date or it's looking somewhere else,
we can check that out later. And I'm
gonna keep looking into the container d,
problem potentially,
I'm guessing,
which if I do, like, a CTR
CLS
inside of the Kate's IO namespace,
assuming that I actually know how to use
container d,
then here we see
there are
image there's containers.
But
so
what is happening here then? Why are there
pods
inside
of CRI,
but then there's no
containers?
That seems odd to me.
Is that because
the container v ones are just
hot sandboxes?
There look to be a bunch of different
images in here in queue, including things from
Cilium and stuff, so
that doesn't seem like it would be accurate.
Running two container runtimes,
and then maybe the Kubelet is misconfigured.
That could be a thing.
Maybe,
it started containers in container d,
and then
now it's not. But that also wouldn't explain
necessarily
why
I I would assume that there's an API
server
running
here. Although, maybe this is just a container
that's created, but that is not actually running.
And since I'm using CTR,
I haven't gotten the status of this thing.
So,
it's not, like, telling me if it's actually
healthy or not. So I should go immediately
be stopped as well, right, or paused
with this functionality
of the container runtime.
I I think it is to see if
PS showed you any of these processes.
Yeah. That's let's let's go down all the
way to the Linux level. Right? That's the
kernel. What do you think? Yeah. And
I tried this earlier with Netstat as well.
Right? And I didn't see a Kube API
server that was bound to any port.
And
now looking in the process table of the
kernel, it's not showing us that there is,
like, an API server per se.
But
I'm also not seeing
the kubelet.
Yeah. That's a problem.
So what's the deal with that? Right? So
maybe,
we should go ask, like, system b,
if it likes
how it life how its life is, like,
right now,
which I think I can just say
system CTL, and then this gives me a
tree, but then I need, like, the status.
And
it's
there's this NGINX service.
So NGINX is actually an assistant d unit,
which I guess is a sensible place to
run NGINX from.
I'm also seeing
there's nothing listed under Cron right now.
And then
we have all these engine x workers processes,
pocket number d.
And then where is where is my Kubelet?
Am I am I missing it? No. I've
had I haven't seen it. And also very
suspicious is the container d three is empty.
And, like, normally, that is huge
at the top.
That's that's up. Did I miss it? Yeah.
It's like the second service and systems like.
Oh, yeah. I was like, we normally would
see container d shims and containers and whole
bunch of stuff,
but nothing.
Yeah. That's a so even
though system d thinks everything is running and
healthy
and that there's no failed units,
clearly, we have some misconfigurations
here, and I don't see the Kubelet service,
which, like, normally, you would, you know, like,
be able to, like, journal a CTL
and then, like, follow the Kubit log.
And I I guess there is a Kubit
log there, but now it says that it
stopped.
Shutting down.
Kubit service successfully entered the dead state,
and then,
I guess, did we disable the system d
unit,
maybe?
I don't even know where oh, I guess
CRI is pointing directly to the container edition,
so that's why
Craig Cuddle is working.
And then container d, like, has some residual
stuff in it, but then the Kubelet's not
running. That yeah. Okay. This is making sense.
So if I go maybe into,
like, some of the
system d,
like, unit tree maybe.
And then maybe we, like, find here and
grab for if maybe the Kubelet service was
just disabled or something.
Here we have the the
kind of leftovers
of config.
And since this is here, I'll just go
and check
that, yeah, this is just a
normal
Kubitium Kubelet extra arcs.
I like your suggestion,
the FireFlash,
just to try and start the Kubelet.
So is there is there no
Kubelet
unit file at all?
Yeah. I don't see the unit file
in in at least inside of the
system d system.
Inside of that c system d, there's no
Kubla unit file.
There was. Sorry?
There was. There there was in your list.
There definitely there definitely was. Yeah. I agree.
Because No. No. I mean, when you looked,
it was listed.
Oh, go go into the system folder.
There should be another
thing in the system directory.
Okay.
This this is just the the service directory.
We'll do an LS system.
Maybe it's just not showing up for the
faint grip. Could be like, that just seems
a bit weird.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Let's
I mean, we got
That'll be inside system.
Yeah. Oh, no. It's not there.
Yeah. I don't I don't see I mean,
I would trust the output of find. Right?
I mean
I mean, I don't trust the f and
f clustered. But
but
yeah. That's
Yeah. There should be a Kiplit
dot service,
which is not exactly a simple unit fail
that tells the head to start.
I
don't have access to the Kubernetes config that
was used to create this cluster, do I?
And, like, normally,
I would, like, try and get that config
outside of or, like, out of the Kubernetes
cluster, but
we don't have a very functional,
cluster at the moment
because we have no cluster.
Oh, okay. If I have the config
file,
then I could just
go and run Kubernetes alpha phase
Kubelet.
So if you go to barlib cache
and grab the dot dev file for the
Kubelet, you could just unzip it and grab
the unit file.
Barrelib cache. You might wanna check the chat.
Check the chat as well.
Have you have you left the unit fail
somewhere for us, Marcus? And that'll save us
the the long way.
I haven't I haven't moved the unit file.
Have a look what the fire flash is
is suggested.
Maybe just try
start. Yeah. So there's from the old media
package can also live in user lib system
d. Yeah. Do a system control status, Kipla.
It'll tell you. Like, we don't yeah. I
shouldn't be making this up. It's just system
d can tell us the
state of the world. There we go.
But as in lab system d system. Thank
you, Kevin.
Yeah. It just says that it was disabled.
And this is exactly what I was but
I was just looking in completely the wrong
path.
Was I I thought it was for hundreds
of these customers, and I was looking at
the wrong path, but don't worry about it.
Yeah. So
this service is disabled.
And
the way that I remember how to do
this on a system the system involves
push putting units into disabled folders with puppet.
I know. You can do system control enable
Kubelet.
Yeah. I just I just need to do
this. Okay.
And then we'll just check the status.
And
here we are. We have it enabled,
and
it's
You're gonna have to do a restart on
it, though, to just to kind of take
it all.
Some
CTL
restart
Kubelet.
That was it gave me a successful error
code. And here we have and then the
Kubelet's entering the failed states, and it says
that
invalid max files one must be greater than
one.
So
is this a sysctl?
Is that what that's referencing?
Because this is like a go
variable of, like, a
max file sysctl.
I mean I had a feeling that I
should have exported all of the sysctls from
my notes when when they were good.
Well, you're gonna run a system control cat
kuplet, and it will show you all the
places that the kuplet is configured.
I would stop there.
Some cuddle
cat.
Yep. Cat kubelet.
So you're gonna see there's
you can ignore the bootstrap one typically, but
FireLib kubelet config might be important. And then
there's the q b d m flags dot
e n v, which you probably wanna look
in. And then lastly, etcetera default kubelet.
Yeah. Okay.
We
can start here.
And what it's meant it's pointing to container
d.
It has the a normal POS container image,
which is definitely a good thing.
And yeah. But this doesn't look like it's
missing anything in particular either.
K.
We have this.
This is gonna be the Kubelet component config,
I think. Yeah. Much longer.
This is maintained by the, Kubelet team. It's
not a Kubernetes API that you can use
inside your cluster.
Right
at the bottom.
Max
files. Container log max files? Oh, okay. I
never used this option ever. But Me neither.
I'm also curious about the max pods at
the bottom.
Max pods? Yeah. That doesn't look really good.
Maybe we could drop that up to, like,
50 or something.
And then
you can have 50 pods on a node.
Right? I think the default is a 10.
Okay.
That's
But you could also just remove it and
have the default. I I assume. I'm not
entirely sure, but I assume. No. You are
right about that because the the structural
deserialize.
And then yeah. I mean, we don't even
need this either.
Volume stats, add periods, sync frequency.
I don't know if zero seconds.
It seems like that's a, like, a default
value.
And then
local
editor is not happy with this terminal size
discrepancy,
but it we're making it work.
K.
We updated the config. Let's go ahead and
just
restart
the Google app,
and then we will look at the Google
channel again.
And at least now, it looks like the
Google is trying to do things. It is.
So that's better than, like, where we were
before.
And then error getting node, this is, like,
not that surprising to me right now because
Kubernetes is not up and running yet.
So, like, it's very natural for the Kubla
control loops to be, like, just throwing up.
Typically, it means it can't speak to the
API server. Right?
Yeah.
But we can, like, check and see. Okay.
We got our pods here, but do we
have our containers?
No.
Why is that?
I just saw a comment from Moz in
the chat.
Static pod path is wrong. Oh, yeah. Oh,
I missed that. Totally.
Thank you.
So
static pod path. Where where are you at?
Here. Yeah. That's not right.
Passes the eyeball test tool.
Manifests.
Etsy Kubernetes manifest, plural. That's probably correct. That
is correct.
Yeah. Resolveconf that we're gonna be piping into
every single pod in the cluster looks okay
too.
Cluster domain is normal.
CIDRs
are normal.
Yeah. I I think that looks good now.
I think Cool. I think so.
Yeah.
Alright.
Now we have a new manifest path. Let's
just go and reboot that Kubelet again.
And then,
hopefully,
you know, like, say we give it a
few seconds, and then we just are, like,
optimistic
that now we have some containers.
That's good.
This is this is a good thing now.
Hey.
We got STD coming up and stuff.
And then from, like that that's like a
container perspective. Now I do see that it
seems like there's, like, a lot of restarts
there. So, like, are these pods, like,
happy?
Yeah. And then
all the base pods are fine, and then
now we're getting some of the, rest of
the
more, like, run time
control plane coming up, like, and
all of these other things that are bootstrapped
into the early Kubernetes cluster. So it seems
like now,
it might be a reasonable expectation to be
able to, like, get some notes from the
cluster, and, that's good. What's also good here
is that our notes are ready.
So that should mean that, like, from a
networking standpoint, we at least have, like, something
that feels like Kubernetes.
And then since I'm thinking about networking and
we're,
like well, you know what? Let's just let's
just look at the deployment,
because, like, the whole point here
is that,
we wanted to
do a very simple thing with a single
application.
But instead,
it looks like we've deployed Argo CD,
and there's also image registry.
And there's a Go CD because we need
a CICD pipeline as well.
And then, why not also have a place
to store artifacts?
You know, like, maybe who knows? Maybe now
we're building, like, a Google on Rails application
instead of, instead of the normal clustered Rust.
Well, you know what? It's nice to see
someone. You know, I saw all these cores
and all this RAM at these clusters. Now
it's finally getting tickled a little bit. So
that's good. Thank you, Marcus. Yeah.
Good question from Russell. Have I gone down
to one worker node? I have lowered this
back to one worker and one control plane
just so that we don't have to keep
fixing things on two worker nodes every week.
I think it's simplified a wee bit. Let's
wrangle in the complexity for me a little
bit. Right? Yeah. So
my intuition here
and
this I I don't know. Maybe, like, should
be good this sometime, but,
I mean, we got some beefy nodes and
nothing is passing the readiness check here.
And why would that be? Oh, we have
Caverno.
That's interesting. Do you think his Argo is
to hide the Caverno deployment? You think it
was an illusion?
I mean, well, there's there's, like, Caverno just
in the middle of the screen. I'm I'm
just assuming that that is
a policy controller that's hooked in with an
admission webhook
to the API server, and that could be
doing all sorts of stuff.
That's actually an area where I don't have
a lot of experience yet. So I'm about
to learn something.
Have ten minutes. Yeah.
Now what can we do in ten minutes
to make this
interesting?
How many hints are here in the, let's
say if, like, I went over to the
root directory? Alright. So we got five hints.
We must have, like, already dealt with, like,
one of these.
Okay.
I mean, you could describe the cluster pods
and see why it's not ready.
Yeah. Let's let's maybe
describe
the deploy
for
clustered.
And here,
we
it says that it's scaled to zero.
Oh, no. That's just the replica set, but
it also is zero desired.
And
Yep.
It's scaled. Yeah. And then, again, I'm not
in a pager, but it looks like you
guys can see most of what I'm seeing.
Yeah. We we can see all. It's definitely
set to zero point replicas. It's saying that
it's pointing to your image of v one.
So I imagine,
if I just try
and
update this, that something is gonna fight me
with all of the stuff that's in this
cluster, but there's no reason not to try.
So I don't know. I I don't Yeah.
Just add it to it. Take it easy,
though. Yeah.
Let's get edit deploy.
What do we got? It's a stem.
This is stem. Yeah.
We do normally two replicas on this. Just
one, but you can go for two. Why
not?
Look at the RAM.
I am in some sort of, like, macro
mode at the moment.
I accidentally
used a different editor shortcuts, and now it's
not letting me hit escape.
Yep. Normal. Same.
I think I'm recording a macro right now
would be my guess.
But
Alright. Someone Google how do we quit them.
I'm trapped.
I
Shall we open a new terminal?
Sure.
Or actually, you know, I can just go
and kill the VIM process myself. Yeah. Go
for it. Why not? Yeah. Here. I I
I have the ability to control my own
destiny.
I just need to TSH
into the
Marcus
control plane.
Marcus control plane one. Yep.
Verb.
Yeah. There was a bug actually in a
recent point version of Teleport that broke control
c. So
but that has been affected, unfortunately.
But that was fun.
It's a it's a VI process.
Right? Mhmm.
I just did a kill all, say kill
v I. Is is a kill not enough
to
winch editor
from the screen?
Oh. Alright.
I I see the process group here.
I believe we're wasting time. It's gone. Let's
just let's just let's just just I've got
a new session.
Okay. Cool. If you just join that. We'll
get the session. We'll add on a couple
of minutes just to get around that.
New session.
It's the one that's from thirty five seconds
ago.
Yep.
Cool. Echo high into it.
Yeah.
Fine.
Coffee.
What's it doing? I was
So you can set editor to, yeah, micro.
There we go.
Okay.
Edit
the
deploy for clustered,
and
I want to find the
replicas.
I should have just used the scale command.
Oh, you were also going to update the
image, weren't you?
Oh, we can't your Salesforce Outlook. So there
is probably Caverno or oh, x five zero
nine certificate is valid.
Okay.
So is the webhook
cert maybe not,
not good,
potentially?
It's
one of the fast way to get that
error again.
To
deploy.
Okay.
It says that it's
scaled
this time.
I feel like that's not right, though.
Okay. It it it has a desired I
was able to patch it.
So maybe whatever that webhook was is only
firing with kubectl apply or something.
But when you issue a raw patch for
the
mutating emission webhook that's configured in Caverno is
not firing on patch or something.
Not not a lot of ideas there. So
I should probably learn a little bit about
the CRDs
that make Caverno work.
So that okay. So I can get the
policies
inside
the whole cluster, and I guess there's
none,
but there might be some cluster policies.
I'm in a terrible time with the editor
size right here. Cluster policies.
There's no cluster policies either. So
why not check for admit mutate in admission
controller at configurations?
Mutate in webpack configurations?
Yeah.
Mutating webpack.
Let's look there. So there's this vault agent
injector.
We could just, like, delete that. Good call.
I think so. Because I mean, like, we
literally have no secrets in our application anyway.
Right? So I just don't trust mutating webhook
configurations. So No. Let's just delete all of
those in all namespaces. Who cares? Yeah.
And then
let's go and describe that deploy again
and see what else it's complaining about.
It says that
it has two desired.
Let's look at the replica sets.
And for clustered,
there's only one replica set, but we
oh, yeah. It should have scaled this replica
set up to two, but it doesn't look
like it did that because this replica set
still says zero.
So what's responsible for that?
And,
that's a good question, but I think I
might just go and try editing the deploy
again,
and setting the container image to v two
because
if
that's, like, the goal anyway.
Failed to call webhook,
validate.
That port four four three is still there.
The Kubernetes
this is saying post to local host four
four three. Okay.
Where is this webhook configuration? It's not a
it's a validating
webhook configuration,
not a mutating one. Let's check them. So
let's go look at those.
And
that was only four eighty five hours ago,
which is the same time that the API
server was modified. I I also don't know
why the API server was modified.
We didn't find any differences in the API
server manifest that we wanted to change at
the time that we had looked at it.
But
I'm just gonna come in here and
delete all of these
as well,
and then we'll try our edit one more
time
and
come in here.
Hey.
So now we were able to actually edit
the deploy.
And
we have
two clustered replica sets. One of them,
has two desired
oh, no. Only one desired.
And then it's not so let's go and
describe that replica set
and see if there's, like, any events or
helpful information about why it's not progressing.
Alright.
It says failed to
create.
Creating pods is forbidden for pod security policy.
Cool. Okay. So just like kinda lots of
policy stuff. Let's go. Let's look at the
look at the PSPs.
This says my scheduler,
and
I I honestly don't know if there's even
any consequence to deleting a pod security policy
because, I mean, we weren't using one in
the first place. Just delete it. Smash, smash.
Marcus
is sad. He says my lovingly classic webhook
was just carelessly deleted.
I didn't even call it by name. Yeah.
And
but
you'll have to send me the write up,
Marcus.
At this point, I'm racing through your your
intricately crafted
monument of Yeah. Of policy. I feel like
we're close. So let's let's give it another
a couple of minutes and see if we
can get this done. Okay. I mean, we're
still making progress. Like, we haven't gotten stuck.
Right? So it's just maybe I'm a little
bit verbose in my approach every now and
then. You wrote, yeah, class instead of grep
plus.
Okay.
Yeah. I I, started typing into some, like,
text that's not part of the terminal that
was just, like, in my p two y,
and, like, I couldn't see.
Hey. Get deploy
r s
pods,
prep for class.
So
we have these replica sets,
and is it, like, still complaining
about something?
If I
go back to what I was looking at
there, it says error creating pods.
And if I
there are no pods.
Yeah. But there's
So I actually caught this at the start.
In the API server manifest,
he enabled a
admission a static admission controller.
Okay. Cool. Let's go take a look at
the
and I don't wanna do this from this
bottom part of the terminal.
Let's
look open a pager at the Kubernetes manifests,
for the Kube API server.
And
you mentioned that there is an admission controller.
Yeah. The part security policy controller
was enabled on this API server.
Right. So that would be the change
that we know
happened,
and it's in this enable
admission controller plugins
flag. No restrictions should be the only thing
that's there. Okay.
If you resize your terminal, it should help
a little bit, I think. I'm not sure.
Resize.
Yeah. Maybe I should make the terminal closer
to the size that it should be.
It's like, unfortunately, I don't know the exact
number columns, and it, like, doesn't tell me
when I'm resizing my terminal,
like, how many columns. But
and it's
manifests kube
API server,
And
looks like I'm kind of closer to where
it should one? So do we want this
node restriction one in in here as well?
We yeah. We do want node restriction.
Okay.
We'll keep that.
And if we do restart
Kubelet just to speed that up. It should
restart our API server for us. Okay. Cool.
Yeah.
And
then maybe we should just take a quick
look at the hints and see what we've
solved so far.
Yeah.
And one, it says
something
hook, probably web hook. Web hook. Yeah.
Web hook.
There's something between us. So that'll be the
NGINX. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We did fix that.
I can't remember. My memory isn't what it
once was. Oh, I don't know if we
did that. Yeah. I'm not sure. No. We
haven't. Marcus says no. Okay.
This one is a very small emoji that
Pause. The pause emoji.
The pause emoji?
Oh.
Okay.
And,
I hope you backed up those config files.
What config files, Marcus? Which which ones?
So what do you think is a good
approach since
we are we've we've kind of run into
the end of time. Do we wanna do
a a walk through the remaining problems?
You think, David? Or Yeah. Marcus, tell us
what what what if we're caught yet.
Okay.
So
you skipped over a bunch of stuff that
was good because I did a load of
stuff in NGINX and all that kind of
thing,
but couldn't get the certificates to play nicely.
So I was just like, yeah, whatever. Just
have it failed.
Mhmm. So that's cool. You saw that I
just absolutely flooded it with
different apps. I basically just went through Artifact
Hub and installed all the top helm charts.
None of those were actually doing anything. So
Caverno was just installed with nothing. There was
OPA on there as well. There was Chaos
Agent,
all sorts of stuff.
Yeah. One you haven't got
regarding memory.
So in the default and the kube system
namespace,
I created a new limit range that limited
the min and max memory to one kilobyte.
Everybody always forget about limit ranges per limit
ranges. Yeah.
So
does this actually affect things, though?
Or It'll
don't know. I I don't know. I just
threw it in there.
I wonder. Because It should affect Cilium. I
would be surprised if Cilium was working at
all, which is probably why none of our
pods are ready and stuck in that zero
Yeah. On the ready stage because there's no
Uh-huh. Working CNI on the worker nodes right
now. So, definitely,
we would just delete the limit ranges across
the entire
cluster.
Yeah. There were actually two of those. There
was another namespace where you had one.
Cool. Okay. That was So the
one,
James has caught it, is around the pause
container.
So when you actually went past it
Did I did I looking at the
at the Yeah.
It's the var
the the Varlib Kubelet Yeah. One, I think.
Yeah. Or or something.
Let's it it was we got there from
system, cuddle, cat, Kubelet,
if I can fill it.
And then,
there is the Varlib Kubelet, Kubernetes, and flags
ENV
really gross Take a look at the last
line.
Yep. Oh, the pod and procuring right there.
Oh, you overrooted over there.
So that's is that, like, an old version
of that container or something,
Or or is that not a good tag?
No. If you actually keep
you scroll across, so you've got some more
width, I think.
If we just count that file, do mind
if I just
Yeah. Where are we in?
This one? It
it looks like there's a
I was at the end of the file
there. You know? I was trying to Is
there is there more?
Okay. Maybe I just completely removed it. That
was weird. It was meant to be the
same
image,
but on the tag for the for the
the the version, I changed the the dots
to underscores.
Oh, just There we go. That you need
to Sorry. I I can see that. I
couldn't see that either.
I think that's the weird scroll bug.
Yeah. I I I can see that. And
I was using a pager, but I I
guess it didn't show up. But, yeah. So
that tag,
is malformed,
which means that the pause container that was
being used by the Kubelet,
would not
get pulled. It wouldn't approve it. Yeah. Yeah.
And so then that prevents containers from starting,
which
would be even if you got the pod
security policy thing done, then you still prevent
containers from starting inside the cluster. So why
do the
why do the static pods work?
Because I, you know, I I would I
I kind of assumed, oh, okay. Well, my
pods are running, so my Kubla is probably
healthy, but, yeah, I guess not. Well,
do they just restart the containers that were
previously there?
Well, this obviously would work regardless of the
CNI because
the CNI is then started by the API
server and other things that keep the container.
So the static pods don't actually need
the pod sandbox
because they're actually matter of pods. So those
are not real pods. They're they're project matter
of projections on the API server.
So
but the pods the pods container is used
traditionally to create
namespaces that the Kubla can create further containers
underneath to support the multi container use case.
But the static pods, I don't think take
advantage of the pods container.
Can the static pods not use
multiple containers?
Oh, I don't know. I guess I don't
know.
You could just schedule them next to each
other in different sandboxes and not have, like,
IPC sharing and stuff. But that doesn't make
any sense because then how would you do
volume mounts between, like, in it containers and
things?
I'll have to look into static static static
manifest must have a whole bunch of restrictions
on them to avoid some of these weird
things. I'm not I there there are restrictions,
but, like, I
I remember when I was developing on Kubadm
that I was surprised at how much worked.
Right? Like, all of the volume mount stuff,
like, projecting things and changing like, that whole
API is
is load bearing,
for all of KubernetesM's configuration.
So
and it's a it's a normal pod spec,
so I would be very surprised,
to have, like, a different behavior,
between, like, multiple containers.
But,
no pod sandbox used for the
for the static pods, I guess.
I mean,
I I guess, like, you could validate that
by looking
inside of
container d
directly,
and
grabbing for the API server,
for instance.
Alright. Are you still on the session? Because
I jumped off. Yeah. Dashing has to go
first,
and you would be correct about that. Yeah.
There's there's no,
there's no pause container
for that. I don't
oh, well, I I mean, it might not
show up because if I look for pause
here,
maybe
those pause containers are used for something else.
It's not the API server. It's my guess.
So
neat.
That's using a different pause container version.
That's not even the version that you linked.
You'd linked it to, like, three forty one
with, like, underscores and stuff. Right? So that
that's just, like, leftover from before, that the
perfect evidence of it not functioning, but the
static pods are still working. So
Alright. Is that is that all, Marcus?
Yeah. You caught the others when when you
well, when I did the typo.
So when you caught that that error with,
like, one
whatever it was, that was because that one
was meant to be one k I.
So it was meant to limit the log
files to, like, nothing
effectively. Yes. Uh-huh.
Yeah. I got a little bit fortunate where
that showed up in the Kubelet log, I
think. That was a that was a nice
quick Kubelet exit as opposed to, like, a
a Kubelet error that's more devious because, like,
the flag
is, like, not functioning,
and Kubelet is still running as a system.
We didn't understand any password.
Yeah.
Pretty. That was so fun. Thank you so
much for for putting that, that puzzle together,
for us to to discover through.
I'm not going to apologize.
Alright. Those were some cool breaks. Now is
now is let's let's at Looking forward to
this now. Yeah. Let's let's get started. So
let's see what Lee has prepared for Marcus.
So, Marcus, I have opened a session or
I'm opening a session on Lee control plane
one. Please just Okay.
Yep.
Join session.
It looks like we have your dot files
as well, Lee. So
Yeah. Nice.
Alright.
So after a quick config, which may already
be set up in the dot fails. Who
knows? And Yeah. Could be. Oh, you've got
some tools coming. Key names, JQ, KibTTL,
SSD control. Hell. Alright. Alright.
Go have some fun, Marcus.
Automated the setup. Yeah.
The Helm one's actually useful. Cool.
So I think Helm's actually already installed, but
just in case.
Yeah. We do use Helm for the the
deployment.
So yeah.
I think you could have broken control plane,
Marcus.
Cool.
Okay.
Let's have a look what we've what we've
got then.
Okay. So let's first have a look at
what we're dealing with.
So okay. So the name's been changed. Let's
let's change that back.
Oh,
you can see still see that. Alright. Yeah?
Uh-huh.
Cool.
Alright. Let's
get rid of that. What else we got?
Okay.
Is your best one?
I don't think so.
No? No.
Okay. That's What are thinking so far about
this error message?
So
the
user
is not what I was expecting. I was
expecting that to be admin, especially as we
changed it.
What else
in here?
So let's see if there's been anything changed
with the Kubelet. No. That's alright.
Okay. So
Good comment there from Russell. Do a dash
v name and check the the debug logging
control if you want. Yeah. Good.
Good point.
Oh, you now you can't see me scroll,
can you? Hold on. That's alright. I'm doing.
Oh, you do? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay.
So
response.
Okay.
So I I kinda feel like this is
a real cube control and a real
API server.
Yeah. It looks alright.
Yeah. Okay. That's the one I pulled
out.
Yeah. Try a cube control
version
curiosity.
If you want a cuter version of kubectl,
there's also kubectl.
What was that, Lee?
There's also cute cute CTL as well over
there. Unfortunately, you overwrote my
my shell script that was telling you to
just mute the. I've
already been forwarded.
Luckily, you're full than I thought you'd be.
So
Okay. So we're able to connect to the
server. We can see the the version's responding.
That
looks correct. Okay.
Let's
Yeah. I didn't have enough time to read
help, and I used to add more.
I I nearly nearly did.
Oh, I can
no. There we go.
Anyway,
Where are you looking?
Yeah.
No. You can't see what I can see.
I can. Yes.
So
now preference to
authorization mode.
Is that authorization mode correct?
That's right. Yeah. I mean, when I first
seen that, I was like, oh, that's been
changed. But now I'm starting to second guess
myself.
I only changed one line in this file.
No.
Okay.
Hey. There you go.
Sorry?
Yeah.
The the only change in this file is
the name.
Oh, here we go.
Well, you can totally just leave it like
that. It's it's completely gone.
What am looking at? Sorry. What's the top.
The metadata name has been changed, but that's
superficial.
So
Oh.
Yeah. Okay.
Does that I don't think that makes a
difference, does it? No. Superficial.
Okay.
So
what else have we got then?
Surely nobody with mass spec kit that.
That would be weird.
Yeah. I I know very little about it,
so
who knows?
Okay. I also I also from
that,
just because I didn't want them to do
the announcements.
Okay.
So we've got some containers.
That's that's good.
See if we've got any pods.
Okay. So we've got
kube calendar.
Okay.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah. Google Calendar. Sure. And
the controller mule. Get it. The Oulu controller.
Yeah. And
Yeah. I I think I think you had
more fun with this.
Okay. So
let's see if we can do anything. So
we can't
can't without the
try without the, dash a flag there.
Okay.
Yeah. That dash a flag, implicitly lists namespaces.
So this is, like, an important thing for,
like, any platform engineers. Like, if you're ever
trying to share a cluster with, like, lots
of tenants and, like, don't want them to
know the namespaces of each other, then it
creates, like, a huge usability issue in quick
control. Because you cannot use a resource name
with a list in Rawkode.
There you go.
I I would have done it otherwise for
you so that, you know, you wouldn't run
into the problem as soon as you did.
Okay. I mean, you only have to modify
cluster, so maybe it's not the end of
the world.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's let's give that a go. Let's
let's see what we can do.
No.
Yeah. Let's not done anything.
Yeah.
Failed to create new replica set. Forbidden
exceed quota.
Oh, quota thing.
Oh, god. I don't know where quota is
a diff a
Well, I would take a look at API
resources.
Would be a good place to start.
Okay. Resells.
Super.
Yeah.
Oh. Uh-oh.
And there's our backbite share.
And have security issues with the kinda own
pods.
Oh, you think you can edit but not
delete? It's sneaky.
I see.
Let's just
yeah.
9,000.
Nice try.
Okay. Run cube control off, who am I?
Just out of curiosity.
Who what? Who am I? Maybe I oh,
yeah. What no no dashes. It's just like
that. Just who am I? Like, the limits
command.
Maybe that's the plug in.
Yeah.
That Well, I think I'll see what The
scenario here is that the
the SRE team
had a meeting,
and
they read this article
from Rawkode Security
about how system masters is insecure.
Because
system masters,
it's the group that's used on the admin
coop config,
and it's it's the group that gets binded
to
by the default cluster role binding.
But if you delete every single RBAC object
inside the cluster, system masters has a by
that's hard coded into the API server.
And it still works. It still lets you
access the cluster even if you've closed your
RBAC.
So I just I I decided,
you know, when I was talking with our
FRA team that,
maybe it would be better if we use
some least privilege roles, you know. Like, you
can get in there and and, like, delete
some sensible pods and stuff if, like, you
need to quickly
change production stuff. But all the policy and
the things that you don't normally wanna touch,
we'll keep that out of the normal RBAC
range.
But, of course, just like any Linux server
that you log into with your own user.
Right?
You're gonna wanna have, like, some sort of
pseudo privilege.
Right?
Well,
one of the hints in there
Oh, what Marcus tried there was switching to
the Kubectlone,
which was a nice try, but that that
would be able to allow you to modify
the r back.
But I would encourage you to run
can I list again and pay attention
to a couple of things in there? Yeah.
I I saw there's the impersonate.
Oh, even before
the impersonate, there's something worth checking out. Oh,
is there another?
I don't actually know if this shows up
inside of Canon or
not.
Yeah. The the thing that you need, it
may not show up there for a peculiar
reason,
but maybe it's there.
Elephant strike is interesting.
You know?
Sorry. Where do you look at? The very
I'm trying not to get too much away.
The first five, like Oh.
Yeah. Sorry. Your scroll is different to my
scroll.
Yeah. It may not show up for you.
Do if you type into the head No.
Yeah. I've I've got it. I've got it.
I've got it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So there's a there's a rather interesting
that you have complete
unfiltered access to something called break glass, which
is interesting.
But the impersonate is also very interesting. So
Yeah.
But I'm curious about break glass. Let's take
a look at that.
So what was that? That was the Cluster
role binding. Cluster role behindings.
Yeah.
I love that everyone watching is getting a
deep dive into every single RBAC object. It's
exactly what the United object community needs right
now.
Oh, I would have expected that to work
because you have unfiltered access.
So it must be the impersonation there.
Yeah. I have no idea how to do
that. Yeah.
So you don't have gets on on cluster
role binding or list and that sort of
thing. But we thought you would do it
on the name, though. So you have to
add the name. So
that's that's that's good to know that resource
name shows up there.
Break dash glass. Break glass. Thank you.
Okay. So it's not inconsistent.
Well, it's not in the namespace because it's
a cluster rule binding. Oh, of course. Yes.
Of course.
But it's not found. Well, that should've worked.
I guess the list fails. Try edit.
You
Yeah. Yeah. I just have to edit myself.
It's it's legitimately not there right now. Alright.
Okay. Alright.
I'm I'm good home. Oh, okay. Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Right. Okay. Yeah. So
can
we create the break glass?
Nice nice idea.
So
hold on. No. That's
a custom role binding.
Right. K.
You gotta find yourself the system masters.
Yeah.
Oh, crap. Yeah.
It has line
If you change using QCTL,
you will have a.
What? Sorry?
If you change your command to use QCTL
instead of QUKE,
like, cute, like, it's super cute, cute CTL,
it will auto complete.
Yeah.
Yeah. But you'd have to find some YAML
for across across the rule by then. Right?
Yeah.
You don't have to. You can totally one
liner these things.
Just maybe look at the help.
It's they're really, really simple once you get
this one.
Oh, yeah. Nice.
Yeah. I actually really like doing a dry
run client
and then outputting normal.
It's usually how I author my cluster role
bindings for my control repo.
Very cool. What
cluster role was it called?
Cluster admin. Yeah. Cluster admin.
You need to bind it to a user.
Oh.
But I'm
I don't have the permission to create.
Oh, that's that's
odd.
Did you tell break glass properly?
Yeah.
Because
I'm pretty sure those it's three
I I did this. I tested it.
And
Did you create a cluster role binding or
a role binding? Let's see. Yeah. Cluster role
binding. It should be cluster role binding. Yeah.
Yeah. Because it says right here, have
any verb on break glass, and then you
should be able to create it and bind
it to
cluster admin.
Yeah. That's great. A oh, the the
yeah. That's the role.
And then it should be your own Oh,
admin. Not yeah. Oh. Yeah. It should be
the Oulu Oulu admin.
Yeah. I I tried to do that. Failed
to create. Okay.
So there's one other solution to this. I
don't know why this is not working
because I have to this make sure I
put basically the exact command
into
the hints file.
Let's let's check the hints. Let's have let's
have a look at them.
Yeah.
Let's let's stop.
So
so there's another solution.
Yeah. Here. Let's just use this other solution
here because
I don't know why your command is not
working, but it should work.
I'll have to look through the history file
that I saved.
Because I I tested it and it functions
properly.
This is a good way to, like, provide
a a way to break glass in a
cluster that you don't normally wanna paint.
So
you we can use KubernetesM and the existing
PKI that's inside of the Kubernetes manifest PKI
directory,
to fix this problem,
by running KubernetesM
certs,
and then there is a a sub command
to regenerate the admin conf. Yes.
Kubernetes search renew, I believe.
No. Oh, yeah. Renew admin, maybe?
Renew all. You don't wanna renew all of
them. Oh, okay. Well, sure. Yeah. You can.
I don't think that that would
spit out the admin prompt.
No. Because there's a special there's a special
sub command for the admin one.
Admin dot com. Yeah.
Okay.
This is the second solution to the problem,
to brute force using the, cluster PKI.
Right.
Cool. So you should be able to,
be administrator now, I think.
Does that to out to the same place?
It's good to spit it out to the
proper directory.
Yeah. Looks like it's been regen. Oh,
interesting.
You may have to restart the API server.
Yeah.
It should just be I don't think that
file got overwritten. Maybe you have to move
like, make a backup or something.
Let's have a look.
Renew.
Additionally, regardless.
Oh, okay. Yeah. No. Okay. Yeah. So it's
there's defaulted.
Yep.
Do you remember that? Error reading configuration from
cluster falling back to the default configurations.
That's okay. We don't use skip proximity cluster.
Yeah. Yeah.
I
I I think we might just need to
move the file to a different name,
just to verify that Deepgram is actually trying
to write it out.
Yeah.
Oh, it says missing.
So there's another way to do
this.
Was it? Nope.
Maybe not.
No. Don't take it. All of the PPIs
are used to do this, and I and
I did generate this earlier as well.
That's so
I
might log in and and tinker with that
cluster role binding command really quick.
Okay. So that
Yeah. You shouldn't need to keep config params.
That looks like it working. Right?
Yeah.
Try try to get pods.
Oh.
Oh, it's been really laggy for me. Are
you are you seeing that as well?
No. It's okay.
Well, that won't restart.
And if I'm just full,
you would have to do it.
Power back is always a pleasure.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. I've got access to the cube
system.
Yeah. So maybe you can grab a
token in there.
Yeah. It's a fair solution. You can grab
a token from one of the
from something.
I don't know necessarily what something might have
the ability to give you.
Oh,
okay. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, one upgrade would be just,
like, being able to see, like,
workloads in all namespaces,
which that would be, like,
a lot of pods.
Yeah.
I'm not sure which of these.
K. So why can you access Kube system
but not
default namespace?
No. I can't. I just can't access namespace
in general.
Mhmm.
So
I can do I can do it in
in the default, but I can't do
so I'm I'm blocked from actually getting namespaces.
Yeah. Since you have access to
secrets
inside of the, cookie system name space,
another avenue for you to do a privilege
escalation in this situation is to
grab a legacy service account token from
one of the more privileged pods.
Okay. What we got?
What do we think? Node controller, maybe?
No. That won't have what you need.
We could just do an anti control delete
of the bad
rule binding. Right?
You could. You have to put through that.
But it's
that you would have less access than before.
Right. Maybe I I don't understand. Well, what
have you done to the Rawkode?
Because I'm I think I'm a bit at
a loss right now.
So I basically
have
issued a new certificate using the Kubernetes alpha,
or the Kubernetes
oh,
sorry. There's another
there's a
do this. Go to Kubernetes on group config.
There there's a whole new stuff to manage
that's GA now,
for this.
Oh. And
what user can we
mint for this? You could mint the user
of, like, a a privileged service account, and
then you have to format the service account
username.
So what I've done is I've minted a
certificate,
and using this and the Kubernetes config file,
you can ask Kubernetes to give you certificates
that are signed by the cluster CA.
And since Kubernetes clusters
will accept
mutual
TLS
client certificate off,
the cert the username that you're trying to
change before, it's actually baked into the x
five zero nine data, and it's it's pinned
like that based on
so that's how you have your identity, that
oOO admin.
And then I've gone in and added privileges
to to oOO admin
to be editor in every single namespace except
for two of them.
And then, also,
I've I added that break glass mechanism
that I I guess I didn't test well
enough.
I thought I used it properly,
and I was able to to use the
mechanism just fine. But I must have accidentally
created the cluster role binding using a higher
privileged account
while I was setting it up. And But
I don't understand why our koop adm search
renew admin.com
used your Mintage username
because it shouldn't. Right?
No.
I don't that's just not producing the admin
comp for some reason.
You didn't change any of these, did you?
No.
No. I the only thing I deleted was
the admin comp.
But, if you
use
anything that might have access to
secrets,
or to
exact in pods.
You could also get the you could also
exact into a pod
from the workload from the working org,
and you would be able to get,
like, tokens that would give you access.
None but I've I've really
not done you any favors, by messing up
that as you go
route there with the, cluster role binding create.
We do anything with the reset.
Screw it.
Okay. That doesn't look like it's gonna do
much.
Did I need to
Kubitiam config in the root home directory?
Yes. I did. Yeah. So
when you use your Kubitiam commands,
you can pass that. That's that's just a
config map from the,
Kube system namespace.
But it's I just wrote it out for
convenience,
so that you wouldn't have to go and
find it.
Kubernetes stores it config in
Kube system.
And, so when you use Kubernetes commands like,
like, Kubernetes, it
acts for the Kubernetes config and as a
flag, and you can pass this. Same thing
for when you, like, renew certs and stuff,
and, this might alleviate
some of the issues that you're having with
regenerating
the admin conf. I think when I was
doing it and testing that roughly, it worked.
I'm pretty sure I've just deleted the cluster.
Oh, did you did you run a Kubernetes
and reset?
I did.
Okay.
Well, I suppose when you and you didn't
take a a TD snapshot.
Nah. That's not from scratch.
And then you'll need to deploy the
the workflow.
Would you like me to add the the
things back that can?
No. I'm just gonna deploy clustered and then
be done with it.
This is this is the bare metal version
of of just rolling the nodes. Right? Why
don't you apply everything back except the RBAC
change? Can you do that?
Yeah. I can. Alright. Okay. Alright,
Marcus. We'll give Lee just a minute to
inject the other breaks minus the RBAC break
because
RBAC's too hard.
I've gotta get get the the node set
up again. Get the hard thing up. Yeah.
Mhmm.
I actually block access to the metadata API
as part of my setup. So you'll have
to do an IP tables dash f to
flush that block.
Capital f.
But you should be able to run the
public IP, etcetera.
Cool. Alright. Well, that's silly. I'm back.
So if you run a get pods dash
capital a as our cluster.
Cool.
Why don't I make this a bit easier
for you? Hold on.
All of the scripts that we use to
build this up is in here.
We can actually just cut the user data,
which will allow us to do some of
it. So let's take I need to maybe
jump. It should be alright.
We don't need this.
I don't need this. I mean, we probably
only need the workload at this point, but
let me just make sure.
There's our QEDM config.
Join config.
Yeah. We don't do any of that. So
all good. All gravy. Let's just skip. Keep
it. Yeah. We're probably gonna need that again
there. So let's start from
here.
I don't have to tell to run that
actually. Wait. I will need to do it
this slowly
where we run the script.
So which one is kubect?
Part 11. Okay. So bash part 11.
12.
Alright.
13.
14.
Fifth deploy.
Oh, I'm just gonna straight to 18 instead
of 17.
At this point, it should be alright, though.
It's just
so this stuff.
Nineteen.
There's our workload.
Come on. Where's our workload? Should we just
come in?
Oh, we don't need teleport. We've got teleport.
Grab workload.
Is Kubernetes now?
Sure.
Alright. We now have a
yeah. We have a working cluster. Oh, we've
now got v cluster in Tanzu being deployed.
I'm assuming that's Julie.
I don't know. It's not gonna be
We will have to remove the tape from
the control plane node so that we don't
have to fix the worker. So if you
could do that, Marcus.
Yeah. Yeah.
Which one's
let's great. Hold on.
Well, I mean, you can just remove the
tint from the node. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'll just edit node.
Please control pin one.
Remove those tint lines. Yeah.
You need to remove 10. Oh,
did that work?
There we go. It
should do.
Right?
Run get pods, and let's see. Alright. Cool.
Alright. Lee, has your break back in place,
or do need a minute?
It
is
I'm waiting it's a it's a competition now.
It's waiting for things.
So just give it a quick moment here.
It might take, like, an actual minute because
I am also installing Kubernetes.
But
because we're there,
and then
it needs to
do this.
And then
Marcus was trying to feed your friend.
Nice try, Marcus.
It's worth a try.
Oh,
I forgot to do a thing. That's the
one I can do. Sorry.
I we're, like, waiting on something that's not
gonna finish until I run this one command.
Okay.
Now
now we should be on the path.
I I needed to add
a a p d c provider
and set it to default.
Yeah. We
have to reassign it.
It's it's there now. And
and now
the the other pieces will fall into place,
and then we will get to learn a
a cool thing.
So
so where's Postgres gone?
I
just
deleted that in anticipation
of it coming back.
But
You deleted the deployment.
Sorry?
I
You know, they Like, the the the deployment
for it's gone or the stateful set. Sorry.
It's we're just waiting for a crash loop
back off. Yeah. It's the the stateful set.
We're just waiting for crash loop back off
right now, and I suppose I could delete
this pod and
expedite this process.
So as the cluster currently broken, Lee?
Is it broken? I mean, no. Can can
Marcus start to debug? I mean, yeah, it
is.
Sorry.
Yeah. Crash the back off. There we go.
Yeah.
I
five seconds.
That CD is
I
don't know why that, PVC is not
because the the the NCD is not running.
I could
yeah. I mean,
there's not
unless I take a different approach to get
the configs onto the cluster
and,
you know,
like, just reprovisioning
the the cluster,
basically,
uninstalled all of this and save.
I mean, can be the m preset as
one way to when clustered. That's for sure.
Save.
Yeah.
But it's sorry. I just, like,
I just wanna I just fast enough.
Alright. Let's call it.
QbDM reset was all was always going to
cause a bit of chaos in the mix
there. But why don't Lee tell us what
what was your your break that you put
together for us?
Yeah.
Well, inside
of a Tanzu Community Edition cluster, we have
an operator called CapController.
And
if you go,
share screen and just go to StealthyBox slash
clustered,
on GitHub.
Alright. And,
yeah.
Here, I just had the the static pods.
It was just the renamed names.
The notes was how I got to the
the cluster,
which includes
setting up the, koop configs,
and applying the RBAC and,
like,
downloading some tools like vCluster,
setting up the vCluster,
installing cap controller,
and then, bootstrapping cap controller with the, vCluster
app. Mhmm. So if you go to the
vCluster app,
YAML,
then, this points to this Git repository,
to the subpack config,
and it applies configuration
relentlessly
just like our friend, Rick Astley.
And, then if you go to the config
directory,
then this is where our GitOps control repo
starts.
So we have that stateful set. We've got
the deployment,
and these are pinned at the version one.
And
then we've got the Cilium network policy,
which was bugged and failed in a way
that was actually worse than what I was
trying to do.
And
then
yeah, and then there was,
the the RBAC here as well is is,
this is where that's managed.
So
yep.
But,
yeah. So just, you know, a little bit
of GitOps, little declarative config. It's like, you're
gonna break something, break it well. Right? So
Oh, hold on. So in that break glass,
you're binding it to the user uwu admin?
Yes. What if me if what if changing
the values in the admin dot conf have
prevented that from them working?
Those values are purely cosmetic for your own
use. Yeah.
They're they're config database values that are unrelated
to the
administrator name that actually gets baked into the
certificate's,
common name.
Oh, it just yeah. Yeah. So it's it's
baked into the x five zero nine, data.
But you when you were doing your cluster
role binding creates,
there were times where you were trying to
bind it to admin instead, just, I think,
out of, like, fresh Yeah. I tried I
tried both.
Which,
that's just my bad. I I I missed
some verbs or something here.
Might need, like, a
Alright. Well, those were both
very boring clusters, but I learned an absolute
lot today from both of you. So thank
you very much for both
breaking and fixing your clusters.
Before we finish up, I'm just gonna draw
the winner for our teacher giveaway.
This is This shirt graphic is so cool.
And
our winners are
here we go. Kira and Omar.
Kira and Omar, congrats.
Alright. And a long cluster
clustered
logo.
Yeah. I'm really happy with the t shirt.
And I wanna see, hopefully, loads of people
at KubeCon
with these. It's gonna be awesome.
And of course, on the back, we've got
a thank you to our wonderful sponsors, Teleport
and Equinix Mill, who help keep clustered teching
along.
All right.
That was a tough one, both of you.
Thank you again for for joining me. We
haven't seen vClustered used in a break, and
I've not seen QPDM reset used as a
fix. So thank you both for bringing us
the first.
The clustered we'll be back next week with
PexiLab
and for
our cluster teams. But until then, have a
great day and weekend, and I'll see you
all soon. Thanks a lot.
Thank you. Bye. Thank you, everyone.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.